you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing
without a master no one gives two
who we are beyond death
the Joker and I broke up I wanted a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only dame in Gotham looking for
emancipation
spectacular news. Miss Quinn, she belongs to me.
who are you guys
Here's the deal, Quinn.
you need me
he's after all of us now
we should order pizza, make cosmos!
I'm the one they should be scared of
who's having a good time
Never call a woman a chick I'll accept
broad, lady, woman on occasion b*tch
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my birds-of-prey trailer
Easter eggs video if you're brand new to
my channel I do DC and Marvel Easter
eggs every week be sure to subscribe to
get everything we have some giveaway
stuff that I'll explain at the end of
the video - even if you're not a big
comic book reader you're probably
familiar with the birds of prey this is
basically birds of prey with Harley
Quinn because when you talk about DC
girl gang related titles usually Harley
Quinn when she teams up with a bunch of
other female DC people it winds up being
villains and they call it Gotham City
sirens right now there actually is a
rumor that the sequel to this movie will
be a Gotham City sirens movie so they'll
do poison ivy and a lot of the other
characters that you would see in a
Gotham City sirens title so if you're
wondering why this isn't Gotham City
sirens it's just that they're building
up to that through probably a new
trilogy starting with this birds of prey
movie but they begin the trailer with
that Harley Quinn voiceover narrating
the premise of the movie a bunch of
second-tier sidekicks and underlings
Harlequins ordered to serve who don't
want to serve at the feet of their
respective masters anymore
black mask is the main villain of the
movie if that wasn't clear you and
McGregor it's not clear exactly why he
wants them to serve so badly there is a
MacGuffin during the movie but this
trailer is meant to give you a better
idea of the broad themes of the movie
doesn't really tell you a whole lot
about the actual plot so it's not that
he just wants them to serve there
actually is something that they did that
he wants to take them down for you see
you're walking down the street with
Cassandra Cain and one of her later
outfits you can kind of chart the
timeline based on the different outfits
that Harley Quinn wear she's one of the
few characters that has a couple really
big wardrobe changes through the film if
you're a big Avatar The Last Airbender
fan fun fact in real life she's actually
the niece of Dante Bosco
Prince Zuko himself this is a shot of
Black Canary singing in black mask club
notice the set design with the giant
black fingers that she's standing
between with those eyes in between is it
black mask is always oppressively
watching everything that everyone does
in the club this person kneeling in the
church could be Renee Montoya Black
Canary or even the Huntress there aren't
that many brunettes that look this young
Harley Quinn trying to sell Black Canary
on the idea
leaving blackmask employee trying to
explain her story how she left the Joker
there's a brand-new DC logo if you zoom
in enhance you can actually see that
it's just meant to be a representation
of Harley Quinn in full Joker makeup
this shot of her cutting off our
trademark pigtails is probably earlier
in the film right after she breaks up
with the Joker she throws knives at his
picture on the wall it is meant to be a
representation of Jared Leto's Joker
picture notice the crazy teeth and the
haircut meant to look just like he did
in the last big Suicide Squad movie my
understanding is based on what people
have said he's not supposed to be a big
on-screen character during the movie but
there is supposed to be some kind of
archival footage or brief flash of him
on screen during the breakup montage at
the beginning of the movie to explain
how she leaves him she talks about
wanting to get her fresh start mentioned
she's not the only damon gotham looking
for one then they do a montage of all
the different birds of prey characters
this is Renee Montoya on the street
trying to investigate this big explosion
there's another shot of Black Canary
looking like she's about to kill herself
she's so depressed the shaking martini
glass is just a reference to her canary
cry abilities but none of the scenes in
this trailer actually let you know
whether or not she'll be a metahuman
during the movie even though the birds
of prey movie is rated R it is still
connected to the other DC films it still
loosely connected the last Suicide Squad
film in Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn is
also starring in James Gunn's Suicide
Squad movie it's not clear if that movie
takes place after the events of this
movie or before it but if they're doing
king shark during that movie there are
metahumans in the last Suicide Squad
movie there are people with magic there
are other metahumans like Diablo so it
wouldn't be weird for Black Canary in
this movie to actually be a metahuman
with canary cry abilities from the
comics this shot of Huntress in the back
alley looking like she's stopping her
stuff from killing someone possibly
Harley Quinn it's hard to tell if this
scene of her is connected to the
Huntress scene might be one of the first
times that they run into each other on
the street
the person that Huntress is connected to
is also black mask and Victor's oz if it
wasn't clear chris messina is playing
Victor Zsasz in the movie he's actually
working underneath black mask
that's why later in the trailer you see
him yelling at Victor's oz saying she's
mine this is black mask getting ready to
interrogate Huntress while she's strung
up upside down noticed the black glove
with the one white finger he actually
does have a black mask of
sorts in the movie and it does seem
based on that viral trailer that they
released with it chapter two that they
are doing the false face society from
the comics I know a lot of you are
excited that they're doing Harley
Quinn's hyenas from Batman the Animated
Series in the comics it seems like
they're only doing one hyena though
instead of doing the two Harley running
through the streets later in the film
black mass telling Victor saws Harley
Quinn belongs to him then her just
playing with her hyena her to tell when
this is happening during the movie but
she's just rescuing Cassandra Kane from
this biker gang if they're connected to
Victor Zsasz or just one of the other
mobs there are many different criminal
organizations and mobs within Gotham
it's a huge city they'll have a way of
explaining why Batman isn't around to
help them with this but for the most
part that narration at the beginning of
the trailer is meant to give you that
idea like nobody cares about us so that
they're trying to say that Batman has
bigger fish to fry than to help people
like them Renee Montoya freaking out in
the streets it also kind of seems like
earlier the trailer that she's either
being kicked off the police force
because she's a detective or she's under
some sort of disciplinary review she's
underappreciated within the department
for some reason she's on the outs with
the Gotham City Police Department we
don't know if Commissioner Gordon is
going to be in the movie at any point but
there are several different police
departments within Gotham so it wouldn't
be weird for him not to be in the movie
black mask's men in the club getting
ready to interrogate Harley Quinn
there's also an extended elaborate barry
marilyn monroe looking dance scene where
she's singing and she has her hair done
up it's hard to tell if that's real and
she's actually putting on a performance
for the crowd or was some sort of
extended dream sequence where she's
imagining all this happening while she's
taking down all these people because
then you see another person in black
mask come out and start shooting all the
other people in black masks black masks
in his bed in his home it's hard to tell
why he's freaking out but this probably
has something to do with why he's so
pissed off at the birds of prey and why
he wants them so badly loved the set
design booby trap this is an amusement
Mile there's a big extended action scene
a big fight scene that they have that
was in the last big viral trailer with
it chapter 2 this is just them getting
ready to start that big fight probably
going to be a lot of joke or Easter eggs
during this part even though he might
not be in this part of the film
amusement Mile is just a big part of
Joker and Harley Quinn's back story in
the comics and Batman
made series so of course they're going to
have a big action scene there during the
film
this is them supposedly fighting the
falseface society we've saw a little bit
of footage that before all those people
wearing the animal masks then there's an
extended scene of Harley Quinn looking
like she's escaping prison with young
Cassandra Cain there is that extended
scene later in the trailer with all
those fire extinguishers going off all
that water everywhere it looks like a
really cool action scene of her busting
in to the prison she looks like she's
there to rescue someone it could be
connected to this Cassandra Cain scene
because they're both handcuffed to each
other and even though Harley Quinn
looked like she's just completely
nonchalant about all this like okay
we're just going to almost hit this person
on the sidewalk as we're swerving around
these cars throw some dynamite in
another car which is total Gotham City
sirens and it seems like this is pretty
early in their relationship because
Cassandra Cain is only vaguely familiar
with Harley Quinn she knows a little bit
about her wait you're that crazy chick
this is Harley Quinn going after a black
mass you can't see him in the back of
the car here but he has Cassandra Cain
in the back of this car he's wearing his
black mask she's on roller skates there
is some roller derby during the film and
they just did reshoots on the movie for
this particular action scene we don't
know exactly when it happens during the
film but it's meant to be one of the
bigger cooler action scenes this is
Harley Quinn trying to sell the others
on the birds of prey team up we should
have a sleepover this is going to be so
much fun let's get some pizza like an
area looking like she's trying to slap
some sense into her come on Harley Quinn
we have a job to do let's go we had you
saw some behind the scenes from the
scene of her in the supermarket with her
walking out with this giant bag of dog
food and a little bit of the scene of
her with the hyena in her car driving
away so it could be from a little bit
later in the film her to tell exactly
when this is happening during the film
inside blackmask club when she's wearing
the pants just one of her other big
wardrobe changes completely shattering
this dus legs look at the girls in the
background reacting like they're getting
ready to throw up at their table another
wardrobe change of her dressed up
incognito
shooting this police officer with the
beanbag gun this might be on her way to
rescue Cassandra Kane from that prison
sequence she says I'm the one that they
should be afraid of you kind of get her
sense for her arc in the film she's
really distraught and pissed off at the
beginning of the trailer because she's
just broken up with the Joker she finds
her confidence through the film and
finally starts ripping shit up
traditional Harley Quinn a comic book
style anytime you see regular
mobsters just wearing regular suits it
seems like it might be something
connected to the Huntress maybe the
Bertinelli crime family they'll have a
way of explaining her backstory too
because it is meant to be the Helena
Bertinelli version of the Huntress
really looks like her hyena is going to go
to town on this dude and he just has no
idea they flashed the title screen just
confirming that the official title of
the movie is birds of prey in the
fantabulous Emancipation of one Harley
Quinn even though they're using Harley
Quinn to heavily market all the movie
she's on all the posters very
prominently this is meant to be an
ensemble film the movies coming out at
the beginning of February so the
probably a bunch more trailers dropping
in December in January of course I'll do
more Easter egg videos if you have any
big questions about the continuity or
where this fits with the other DC movies
that are connected with sort of the
Justice League continuity just let me
know in the comments because James
Gunn's Suicide Squad movie isn't coming
out till august 2021 they're shooting it
right now
I assume that whatever's going on with
Harley Quinn during that movie will be
said after the events of birds of prey
so technically not connected to Matt
Reeves Batman film there's all kinds of
rumors about how they're spinning out
Batgirl and a whole bunch of other
Batman related characters like Nightwing
within Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves
Batman trilogy but I'll do more videos
about that when we get more details they
won't be shooting that till either
really later this year or early next
year you know obviously this movie is
not connected to Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
movie it's out later this week of course
I'll post my full review video and
Easter eggs
post credits scenes all that kind of
stuff later this weekend so be sure to
go see the movie when you get a chance
we are doing a giveaway for Joker movie
tickets all you have to do to enter that
just be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about the birds-of-prey movie on
the video
everybody click here for my non-spoilery
Joker movie review and click here to
learn why Marvel got Spider Man back in
the MCU from Sony thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!